while everyone's focused on the
president in his cost cutting proposals
yesterday there was a hearing that got
little to no press on Capitol Hill it
focused on the Muslim Brotherhood the
chair of the house Intelligence
subcommittee on terrorism Sue Myrick
raised the red flag that the US doesn't
have a strategy to deal with a shadowy
group that's trying to assume power in
Egypt the federal government does not
have a comprehensive or consistent
strategy for dealing with the Muslim
Brotherhood and its Affiliated groups in
America America nor does it have a
strategy for dealing with the
Brotherhood in Egypt or the greater
Middle East we need to examine closely
whether its true goal is setting up a
worldwide Islamic regime is still in
place here now with our thoughts are Dr
zudi jasser president of the American
Islamic forum for democracy and Robert
Spencer director of jihad watch and
author of stealth Jihad how radical
Islam is subverting America without guns
or bombs Dr jesser let's start with you
because you were one of the key
Witnesses in um representative Peter
King's Homeland Security um hearings a
month or so ago tell us what you thought
about the hearings today in the
hill yeah I can't tell you how important
they are and how much of a service
Congressman my Rick and the Witnesses
were doing in bringing to light a
subject when I talked about
radicalization I talked about a
Continuum the fact that it's not just
the violence at the end but there's an
ideology that separates some Muslim
youth not all a minority but a radical
minority from the society which is
related to a slippery slope of political
Islam and we've been playing defense
against ideology that's not only
domestic but Global and the Brotherhood
has been the primary cancer cell and she
really brought to life some very
academic poent testimony about the fact
that we've had no strategy we've been
fighting a a cold war of ideas not only
just playing defense but with no
strategy at all and if we're going to
penetrate the ideas of political Islam
all around the world we need to enable
liberal secular Muslims to start to
fight this on the ground to begin ideas
of Reform the separation of mosan state
and to fight this offensively which we
have had no strategy of doing no
strategy uh Mr Spencer one of the things
that concerned us most about U Egypt
when Mubarak stepped down was this in
fact problem of the Muslim Brotherhood
making their way in do we know if the
Muslim Brotherhood is making inroads
into Egypt now it's happening more
quickly than anybody could have
anticipated Eric you know not long ago I
was on your show follow the money and I
said the Muslim Brotherhood is poised to
take power in Egypt and Juan Williams
said I was fear-mongering and now I just
want to say to Juan Williams and to
everybody else I told you so I tried to
tell you the Muslim Brotherhood won 77%
in a referendum just weeks ago in Egypt
to change the Constitution that will in
ways that will pave the way for its
taking power it is clear that it is the
largest group uh in Egypt in opposition
and the one that is poised to take power
there and so they're going to establish
an Islamic State and we also have to
remember the representative my is right
the Brotherhood is in the United States
also so we'll get to the US uh Dr jaser
less than 30 seconds or so tell us is
this a different Muslim Brotherhood than
the one we know from past uh I guess
terrorist
ties yeah their core ideology they may
isue violence but their core ideology of
Islamic supremacism establishing an
Islamic State through Sharia law is
still in place they've never condemned
that and they haven't stepped away from
it but I hope people understand that we
need to get out of the morass that
created these groups which was the
dictatorships in the Middle East and we
may step backwards first but the
progress in the Middle East may seem
messy but it's the only way out of this
Robert and Eric and I hope people see
that this is the only way out is to get
rid of these Thugs and put and get us on
the ground to help mobilize them towards
some type of secular democracy all right
we're going to continue this discussion
we're going to take it to how it's
affecting us right here in the United
States after the break more with Dr uh
zudy jasser and Robert Spen answer in a
couple of
minutes we're back with Dr Audi jasser
president of the American Islamic forum
for democracy and Robert Spencer
director of jihad watch Mr Spencer you
touched on it in the last block let's
talk about it now how does what's going
on in Egypt in fact even in Libya affect
us here in America well Eric we have to
remember that the Muslim Brotherhood has
a strategic goal for the United States
that was delineated in a captured
internal document that was Unearthed a
few years ago and it's it dedicated in
the United States in its own words to
eliminating and destroying Western
Civilization from within that same
document lists all the major Muslim
organizations in the United States as
Muslim Brotherhood linked organizations
including the Muslim American society
the Council on American Islamic
relations parent group The IAP the uh
Muslim Students Association the Islamic
Society of North America these groups
are Brotherhood groups that are working
in the United States to subvert the US
Constitution and ultimately to replace
it with Islamic law and we have to
recognize that and recognize that that's
a political agenda that free people need
to fight and resist Dr Jer do you agree
with Mr Spencer I mean the one that
really sticks out for me is Care Council
on American Islamic relations they're
very much out there they're they're very
much uh trying to paint the picture of
uh Muslims being not extremist not
radical but Mr Spencer says maybe they
are what do you
think well I think you know many of our
families came to the US to escape sort
of these islamist groups that claim to
speak for us and Care is one of those
examples I mean one of the best examples
Eric is just a couple weeks ago there
was released and published on Fox
news.com a letter that nihad Awad the
head of care sent to the Gaddafi Thug
asking for $15 million for his peace
foundation in which he wanted he called
Gaddafi the Excellency of Islam the
great Muslim leader Etc so you see how
important it is that these dictators are
completely ined with the Muslim
Brotherhood front groups these Legacy
groups that claim to speak for Muslims
but they're all about control
collectivization of our community trying
to say that we all speak as one rather
than the diversity that we really are
which is those of us that want Liberty
that want freedom that want separation
of mosan state and want to stay away
from groups like care and Brotherhood
type mentality um Mr Spencer let's say
the Libya right now I mean there's
there's a power struggle going on in
Libya frankly it may divide the country
in half or one either the rebels or
Qaddafi could could win out but if the
rebels take over do we know that there's
no Muslim Brotherhood or even Al-Qaeda
or Taliban involved with the rebels well
actually we know just the opposite we
know that there's a significant Al-Qaeda
presence among the rebels we know that
one of their trainers is a Guantanamo
detain who was released uh in 2008 we
know that uh Eastern Libya the center of
resistance to Gaddafi was also the
center of jihad Warriors going from
Libya into Iraq more came from that area
of Libya than any other region of the
Islamic world into Iraq to wage Jihad
against American troops there and so
this is the resistance to Gaddafi here
again just as in Egypt we're going to
see an Islamic State in Libya following
Gaddafi that's going to be even more
hostile to the United States than he is
Dr jesser very quickly the rebels have
asked us for a$2 billion loan a little
help there would that be a good idea or
a bad
idea well I think the only money we
should be putting in is money that we
follow in with people on the ground to
help them build institutions not from
arms length but us working with secular
Democrats on the ground for Solutions
because these problems we keep talking
about exist but they exist because we've
sort of left the Middle East to be at
the hands of dictators and it's time for
us to get the ideas of Liberty infused
on the ground so that we have The
Advocates like we did in Poland Romania
Czechoslovakia when those dictatorships
left we went there and advocated for
freedom and we need to help them build
those institutions but not just dumping
money in it we need to follow
fascinating fascinating topic thank you
guys Mr Robert Spencer and Dr zy J thank
you guys